il ne s'est pas écoulé un jour pendant
ma campagne sans qu'un chef d'entreprise
me disent je ne trouve pas demandeur je
suis obligé de fermer mon restaurant un
jour deux ou trois jours par semaine je
ne peux plus ouvrir le soir
[Musique]
je suis obligé de faire travailler
ma femme ou mari avec moi on s'épuise au
travail on n'y arrive plus
mais dans des tas de domaines dans
l'industrie moi je viens d'une région
qui est industriel qui est très
touristique aussi c'est si terrible là
véritablement neutre ou tissu économique
est en grand péril en péril mortel parce
que s'il ya pas de manoeuvre y a pas
d'activité ce n'est pas l'activité il
n'y a pas de ressources est on ne peut
plus fournir les services
auxquels évidemment chaque français
est en droit d'attendre d'abord la
question de la formation
il faut absolument que l'information
sera proche des besoins du monde du
travail ça n'est plus possible de former
des jeunes qui vont
aller dans des filières où il n'ya pas
de recrutement ou les dissuader d'aller
dans les filières qui ont de l'avenir et
donc le constat n'est pas nouveau moi ce
que je déplore c'est que on est très
fort sur les constats mais que les
solutions vraiment tarde pas à arriver
donc il faut être
courageux c'est une réforme difficile
mais manifestement la réforme de
l'indemnisation du chômage et de la
formation qui a été fait sous le
précédent quinquennat ne suffit pas on
en a la démonstration avec vous demi
avec vous de munich avec tant d'autres
et puis le deuxième sujet s'est
orientée la main d'oeuvre vers les
métiers en tension
pendant la campagne présidentielle il ya
une proposition qui était très
intéressante que nous avait en fait qui
consistait à verser 700 euros de mémoire
à des jeunes par mois à la condition
qu'ils se forment dans les métiers en
tension
j'ajoute que il faudrait pouvoir avancer
sur la fidélisation d'une main d'oeuvre
qui est formé dans l'entreprise quand
l'entreprise fait l'effort d'accueillir
des
dix alternant
et bien il faudrait que l'effort de
formation qu'elles consentent puissent
être compensées corrélée à un engagement
du jeune à rester dans l'entreprise au
moins l'équivalent du temps de sa
formation mais là c'est une proposition
qu'il faudrait pouvoir faire aboutir
mais les résistances il n'y en aura j'en
suis persuadé mais quand il ya une
volonté forte il est possible d'y
arriver